as the floodwaters rise river banks are
giving way at least 1200 people have
been rescued from low-lying villages
along the sutlers River in Punjab
province it's a desperate race to save
as much of the standing crops as
possible many farmers are refusing to
leave their livestock and crops behind
Hassan Imam Lopez this happens every
time India releases water and homes get
inundated our crops worth millions have
been destroyed the government has given
us a few larger boats to evacuate people
and their livestock but we think the
situation will improve in the coming
days
provincial rescue teams and military
personnel have been deployed but those
rescued say the situation in far-flung
villages is bleak and water levels were
still rising when they left India
released the water and you can see our
livestock and everything is still in the
village we are desperate please help us
take out our livestock nearly half of
our people are still stranded Indian
officials say they had to release large
quantities of water from the Bhakra dam
they say the area has seen the highest
rainfall in 40 years resulting in
unprecedented high levels in the
reservoirs politicians in Pakistan say
India did not provide prior warning
before releasing the water which it's
supposed to do under a decades-old
bilateral agreement Pakistan's National
Disaster Management Authority says
thousands of hectares have been flooded
to Lake and 40,000 q6 of water has been
released in rivers set floods which is
not a light River in in Pakistan because
there was no warning or alert issued by
the Indian Authority being the upper
riparian country and we are the lower
riparian country but now we are
monitoring and their head works release
of water officials say saving lives is
the priority and they hope water levels
will recede in the next 48 hours but it
is the monsoon season and heavy rainfall
is expected in northern India in the
coming days which means more water will
flow downstream many rivers are flowing
higher than usual
monsoon brings with it rain floods and
destruction every year but this time
around amid heightened tensions between
Pakistan and India even the stoppage and
release of water has been recognized the
psalm of in Java Dada Zira on the banks
of the Jhelum River